cuántos términos contiene la expansión
binomial de x al cuadrado más 2 al cubo
todo esto a la veinteava potencia
y puede ser que cuando ustedes vean esta
potencia de 20 piensen que les tomara
una eternidad resolverlo pero recuerden
que solamente no se están preguntando la
cantidad de términos pensemos un poco en
ello si yo tengo por ejemplo x +
a la 1 esto implica pues que tengo nada
más x más es decir tengo nada más dos
términos si aquí yo tengo x más al
cuadrado
voy a tener x al cuadrado más 2x y más
ya al cuadrado es decir voy a tener tres
términos vamos a hacer esta x + d al
cubo
y aquí podré usar una expansión binomial
con un triángulo de pascal por ejemplo
en un triángulo de pascal si yo tengo
para la primera potencia
aquí un 111
para la segunda potencia voy a tener
aquí
1 11 12 y aquí uno para la tercera
potencia voy a tener
acá y acá
232 más 13 y aquí uno entonces para este
que es al cubo voy a tener
x al cubo más
3x cuadrada 3x cuadrada por jane más 3
x
cuadrada más y al cubo es decir tenemos
1234 términos
ustedes toman cualquier binomio y lo
elevan a la tercera potencia terminarán
con cuatro términos y depende de con qué
lo razón en con el triángulo de pascal
cada vez que bajamos agregamos un
término más aquí por ejemplo el de la
cuarta potencia
bases
estos coeficientes
1 3 + 1
4336 3 + 1 4 y aquí uno va a tener 1 2 3
4 5 términos si ustedes consideran la
expansión binomial en ese también
tendrán de un binomio a la enésima
potencia n más un términos en este
ejemplo tenemos un binomio o sea que es
un polinomio con dos términos elevado a
la potencia 20 recuerden que la tercera
potencia tiene cuatro términos y la
cuarta potencia cinco términos así que
la potencia 20 tendrá 21 términos que es
mi opción ve muy bien pasamos al
siguiente problema
son los primeros cuatro términos de la
expansión de 12 x 6
pensemos primero en los coeficientes
esto va a ser igual
de 6 selecciono 0
16 x 2 x 0 más de 6 selecciono 1
21 a la quinta por
2x
cada uno
más de 6 seleccionados por
1 a la cuarta por 2 x al cuadrado
continúa aquí abajo más
de 6 selecciono 3
1 al cubo por 2 x al
entonces aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 términos y
para dar tiempo veamos las opciones
vemos que el primer término aquí que nos
dan en las opciones el primer término es
el mismo el segundo término también es
el mismo y aquí en en tercer término es
donde podemos ver que hay diferencias
así que analicemos el tercer término qué
diferencia tenemos ya sabemos que el
primer término este va a ser igual a 1
como está acá este segundo término va a
ser igual a 12 x
ahora vamos a analizar este tercer
término para ver qué opciones podemos
descartar
así que vamos a traducir esto
de 6 seleccionados es lo mismo que tener
6 factorial entre 2 factorial por 6
menos dos factorías y esto es igual a lo
escribimos por acá
6 por 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 sería por 1
pero lo mito entre
2 factoriales 2 x 1 pues va a ser 2 por
6 menos 2 va a ser 4 factorial así que
va a ser por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 así que
puedo eliminar esto de aquí con esto de
acá y me va a quedar incluso puedo
simplificar este 66 entre 2
por 33 por 5 es igual a 15 así que esta
esta parte de acá es 15 al menos esta
parte estoy acá voy a seleccionar bien
que esto de seis seleccionados es esto
me falta multiplicar este 15 por 1 a la
cuarta que es 1 me queda 15 por 2 x al
cuadrado
que es igual a 15 por 2 por 2 4 x
cuadrada que es igual 15 por 4 60 x al
cuadrado y vemos de las opciones pues la
única que tiene 60 x al cuadrado es la
opción de así que esta base es mi
respuesta solución a este problema
siguiente problema cuál es la suma de la
serie geométrica infinita un medio más
un cuarto más un octavo más un
dieciseisavo etcétera
seré honesta ahora recuerda la fórmula
pero en muchos momentos se nos va a
olvidar esta fórmula y hay un truco para
recordarla para volverla a deducir
cuando la olvidemos
tratando de encontrar la suma infinita
de una serie geométrica y voy a volver a
deducir la fórmula tengo la suma igual
un medio a la 1 más un medio al cuadrado
más un medio al cubo más un medio a la
cuarta
etc esto lo sumo infinitamente esto de
aquí es lo mismo que tengo acá ahora
multiplicamos un medio por ese un medio
por s
esto aquí va a ser igual bueno tendría
que distribuir este medio en todos estos
términos un medio por un medio va a ser
igual a un medio
al cuadrado un medio por un medio al
cuadrado va a ser igual a un medio al
cubo un medio por un medio el cubo va a
ser igual a un medio a la cuarta
así sucesivamente
ahora déjenme preguntarles algo si yo
resto esto
- esto de acá
que me va a quedar voy a restar lo verde
de lo amarillo pues si hago esto si hago
esta resta
todos estos términos se me van a
cancelar y solo me voy a quedar con ese
menos un medio de ese igual a un medio
que es aquí no tengo ningún término con
que restarlo y este es el truco y lo
pueden demostrar de manera general
aunque esto es interesante porque
normalmente estas series comienzan con
un término elevado a la potencia cero
pero este problema comenzó con un
término elevado a la potencia 1 así que
ese menos un medio de ese pues va a ser
igual a un medio de ese un medio de ese
esto es igual a un medio multiplicamos
ambos lados por dos esto lo multiplicó
por 2 y esto lo multiplicó por 2 esto se
va me queda ese esto se va me queda 1
por lo que es esta suma va a ser igual a
1 existe una fórmula que dice lo
siguiente
la suma
desde n 0
tiene igual a cero hasta infinito
a la n que en este caso es un medio va a
ser igual a 1 entre 1 menos
su reacción natural pudo haber sido
bueno esta suma que vimos es igual si lo
sustituyó estos valores de este problema
esta forma va a ser igual
desde n 0 hasta infinito
a quedamos que es un medio elevado a la
m por lo que es igual a 1 entre 1 menos
un medio igual a 1 entre un medio
esto va a ser igual a 2 y hubieran dicho
caray pues en donde me equivoqué y les
mostraré en dónde está el error
esta suma comienza con m igual a 0 y el
valor de un medio a la 0 es igual a 1 y
aquí en este ejemplo no tenemos ningún 1
con la que comienza nuestra serie por lo
que este término no está contemplado
aquí este es de que es igual a 1
así que si yo tomo este valor y le restó
este término que no existe
voy a tener dos menos uno igual a uno
que es igual a esta respuesta que obtuve
es por eso que memorizar fórmulas y esta
es una buena fórmula para memorizar esta
de aquí es buena para memorizar lo malo
es que a veces puede ser confuso ya que
por ejemplo en este caso en el no
comienza en cero comienza en uno que
pasa cuando esta serie comienza no en
cero sino en uno
este programa me gustó porque no se está
probando para ver si de verdad
comprendimos este concepto nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo